direction l'ukraine au moins 35 morts et
une centaine de blessés ce matin dans
une attaque sur la gare de cramât torse
qu un bilan de sources humanitaires des
roquettes ont touché des civils qui
tentaient de s'enfuir vers des zones
plus sûres moscou dément être à
l'origine de ces tirs de missiles on
retrouve tout de suite sylvain rousseau
notre envoyé spécial à lviv on attend
aujourd'hui la visite tour sous la faune
vers la hyène la présidente de la
commission européenne et de josep
borrell le chef de la diplomatie cette
visite marque le soutien politique de
l'ue rope à l'ukraine mais qu'attendent
les ukrainiens de cette visite
écoutez du côté des ukrainiens en tout
cas ici à lviv on se félicite malgré
tout de cette visite même si tout le
monde est conscient qu'il s'agit d'abord
d'une visite symbolique notamment
destinée vous l'avais dit à marquer le
soutien pour l'instant indéfectible des
européens à l'ukraine est également
destinée à marquer bien ce cinquième
train de sanctions qui a été pris à hier
soir mais du côté de la population
ukrainienne on n'en réclame plus plus de
sanctions plus de soutien militaire plus
de sanctions on rêve ici en fait que
l'union européenne puisse faire front
commun et tout simplement et bien
décrété un embargo sur le pétrole sur le
gaz russe de façon à couper le
financement russe a coupé à arrêter en
fait les fonds avec lesquels la russie
et bien finance cette guerre en ukraine
mais c'est vrai que la visite d'ursula
von der leyen vous l'avez dit avec les
bombardements des gars avec les dizaines
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés
qui recommencent à prendre le chemin de
l'exil depuis depuis l'est depuis le
donbass et bien cette visite passe ici
un petit peu au second plan même si eh
bien on loue également le le courage des
deux dignitaires européens qui se
rendent qui choisissent d'aller en
ukraine deux se rendent à kiev et en
plus de ça de se rendre à kiev en train
alors que vous l'avez dit plusieurs une
gare a été bombardée 7 me faisant de
nombreuses victimes et également des
voies ferrées qui pour l'instant est
bien empêchent les civils de fuir cette
région de l'est merci beaucoup sylvain
rousseau